le chemin fait disait non on a fermé la
traque on entretient plus que j'ai
terrain tout le monde connaît l'histoire
on s'envoie la cause les jonctions qui
est kimi flammes un règlement qu on
sente 1 on y va un hôtel 4 ans mona
fasse encore une inspection et cette
fois ci l'ont fait avec le spi ricard
fameux détecteur de failles chez terra
pourra prendre 48 heures après que la
reine n'était pas potable
donc on ne peut pas y aller on a peur on
nous présente les mains encore une fois
nous les détails de sa passer par nous
que dans ce panel s'adresse s'adresse
pour chemin de fer qui détient deux
syndicats des petites salles et pour
cela vous était dans cet état avant
l'accident
présenté à deux belles lettres un de
vela
moi je me tiens montagne procès des
trains là dessus durant toute l'année
présenté passes sont passés des convois
de très automnal sur ce chemin de bons
copains km five j'ai aucune idée mais
nous on a appris que deux jours après le
passé un court qu'il envoie ta propre
aux tables séparées soir c'était parce
la fac tivement nous ce qu'on souhaite
encore si je parle pour l'industrie du
train touristique qu'on devienne des
grands garçons des grandes filles c'est
à dire des compagnies qui exploitent on
fédéral avec un statut qui fait qu'on
peut répandre de manière sécuritaire
dans cette exploitation directement par
les autorités je souhaite que des
avancements là-dessus notoire c'est
drôlement important qu'on arrête d'être
dépendant comme nous sommes là